[Music]  sound a little different  hey everybody look it's noisy my co-star  from Tex Johnson my name is Kade it  supposed to balls  Adam King get $75 first signature green  this for the money  Gold is water honey Gill is the Tony  Montana of super cards we dress up we  still the stache and we walk out like  nothing ever happened  you guys know this is a dumb idea right  oh yeah we do  I'm in said what do you think you win  yeah I mean KZ they're robbing from us  we want to take it back to the fans this  kid just monologue let's rob super Khan  you have to get that money before it  gets backstage and in McCain's hands are  you wearing news well more of go-go  boots yes  I can't believe  like making out with David Lee Roth  don't know  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you